switzerland famous for this mountain
clocks its interesting banking
arrangements and of course its
neutrality whereas in the past it was
primarily known for its mercenary
companies and their ability to wage war
so what exactly changed why did
switzerland go from a land of soldiers
for hire to one of non-involvement and
why did the countries around it which to
understate things really like to fight
their neighbours allowed this to happen
so exactly when switzerland became
neutral is debated in the 16th century
it wasn't a formal nation but loose
confederation of smaller states which
were part of the holy roman empire there
was a scuffle in italy over whether or
not francis the first of france was in
fact the ruler of milan and since the
swiss had a claim to it themselves it
was time to fight the swiss lost and as
a result they pledged themselves to a
perpetual peace with respect to france
but you know who isn't france savoy and
when france marched into northern italy
20 years later the swiss helped
themselves to this land after this
switzerland largely stayed out of wars
barring the supply of mercenaries during
the 30 years war keeping this piece
wasn't out of any desire to maintain
their neutrality but for two reasons the
first was that the states around them
were much larger and getting invaded by
them sucked the second was the
protestant reformation which meant
instead of worrying about events in
italy france or the holy roman empire
they now had to worry about their
neighbours who suddenly believed
different things this internal conflict
managed to keep the swiss occupied until
1798 when its neighbours with shiny new
political ideas invaded the swiss
confederacy fell apart quickly and it
was replaced with the brand new helvetic
republic which was stripped of this
territory napoleon soon changed his mind
and reformed the confederacy well most
of it is a french puppet state but after
he was ousted the victors all had
different plans for switzerland the
french plan for switzerland wasn't heard
since they had just lost the war and so
be quiet the prussians wanted
switzerland to be forced into joining
the german confederation and the
austrians wanted it to become an
austrian puppet state and buffer against
the french in order to avoid any
conflict the russians mediated and
everyone agreed that the swiss
confederation would be forever neutral
and wouldn't send troops abroad except
for the pope that is he could have some
everyone accepted this until the late
19th century when it became a haven for
socialist bonapartist nationalist and
liberal dissidents from the great powers
as such the surrounding great powers all
demanded that the swiss keep tabs on
these people which they begrudgingly
agree to and now could actually do since
the recent civil war there had made it
into a much more centralized federal
state so given that the european powers
felt free to threaten switzerland
whenever it suited them how did it stay
neutral and not get itself belgium well
the first real threat to swiss
neutrality was the first world war the
danger didn't come from germany they had
other neutral nations to cross but from
france as the war raged on the french
wanted to flank the german army in the
south and so came up with a brilliant
idea of going through switzerland
hearing of this the swiss mobilized more
of their army and placed it on the
french border and this greater
resistance combined with the likely
backlash from britain meant that
switzerland was spared and after the war
its long-standing neutrality was also
part of the reason why it was chosen to
be the headquarters of the league of
nations and world war ii was the last
time that switzerland's neutrality was
threatened german leadership had wanted
to expand under the pretext of german
unity but they never invaded the country
for several reasons first of all a
neutral switzerland made for a useful
diplomatic trade hub since german and
allied diplomats could unofficially make
contact germany could also sell gold
that it had acquired to switzerland for
swiss francs which it could use to
purchase goods from third parties the
second reason the most important one was
that the costs far outweighed the
benefits switzerland was a mountainous
land with little in the way of natural
resources populated by a fiercely
independent people who were mostly armed
to the teeth and given that germany had
either bigger plans or much more
pressing issues the opportune moment to
invade never presented itself and after
this switzerland was able to maintain
its neutrality with no further threats
of war which is why geneva was made host
to a major u.n office in 1946 an
organization which the swiss refused to
join until 2002. i hope you enjoyed this
episode and thank you for watching with
a special thanks to my patrons james
bisonette kelly moneymaker core show
wolf jordan longley adam stalter jerry
lambda marcus arsenaulian hockey words
about books podcast rodney martin
captain cydog marvin cassel gustav swann
spencer lightfoot boogerly wuggly kamoon
yoon winston k wood aaron the white
matthew shipley alex schwinn max and
flaudio maggie patzkowski anthony
beckett the mcquapper corey turner
coppertone spinning through plates
charles the first ben evanson and
scottish trekkie